[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy hump day gobble gobble gobble in
his Thanksgiving week
and another mass shooting
welcome to America
you're not safe and Church
an elementary school classroom
or a Walmart break room in this country
You're Not Safe anywhere matter of fact
and if you're out there traveling be
safe
you're likely more probably more likely
to
catch a bullet than to catch a fender
bender this holiday season last night
Virginia a manager of a Walmart
walked into the break room and started
firing a weapon killing people
because uh guns
that's why
they've already started the mental
health thing which
you need a [ __ ] break Glenn youngin
Virginia
he already the governor of Virginia
Glenn youngin
talking about Mental Health
foreign
ERS do as much about mental health as
you do about guns
if you're standing around still
wondering why we got a [ __ ] problem
in this country
with guns gun violence
people killing other people with guns
it's because we still have Republicans
in power places
that's why
it's beginning to be that this isn't our
gun violence problem
is a republican problem
and I'm blaming it on every [ __ ] one
of them every single one of them
that's right [ __ ] them let's let's pull
it aside the [ __ ] out of this you know
me I don't give a [ __ ] what politicizes
to any issue I don't give a damn
it's the best way to do things anyways
when you're going to play politics with
it oh Mental Health
okay Glenn youngin then do something
they ain't gonna do [ __ ] about Mental
Health
I care less about your [ __ ] mental
health frankly they want you [ __ ] on
on the verge of lunacy
that way they can really Stoke you into
terrorism
by scaring you with transgender people
oh [ __ ]
and people gonna take away your [ __ ]
that you ain't got
because we've been taking it
really is something in this country it's
gun culture [ __ ]
you're gonna get to talk about it over
the weekend of the long holiday weekend
they were like oh you [ __ ] yeah
you're gonna have your dumb [ __ ] cousin
Daryl and his dad Earl your Uncle Earl
Thanksgiving dinner to talk to about
this I ain't [ __ ] you
they're gonna be there
talking about how well God damn if
someone would have just had a gun in
that in that Walmart
well [ __ ] if they stop if they stop
being pedophiles they'd stop getting
shot
they're gonna say two different things
at once
those are two different things
we've had two mass shootings
under under two different circumstances
last week
one kill five last night I think the the
count is seven
all right lose track you lose track how
the [ __ ] are you supposed to keep track
every [ __ ] day eight here nine
there three here four there
it's like a [ __ ] auction
give me seven
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
two mass shootings under two different
circumstances I don't know what the [ __ ]
this manager was thinking in Walmart
and he just pissed off pissed on I I
can't [ __ ] figure it out I don't know
then you have the Maga shooter the Maga
assassin
the domestic terrorists
that goes into Club Q
and kills people for who they are
it's all by Design
both of them both situations by Design
you don't think gun manufacturers
want to keep you in fear of guns
listen the gun culture problem that we
have in this country
is not that we're absolutely obsessed
with guns that's not that's not exactly
the problem
I mean there's a handful of people that
are just [ __ ] absolutely obsessed
with guns
which I don't know that that's you know
I mean it can be a bad thing but I mean
just because you like guns or you have a
lot of knowledge of them
I like to shoot them
want to be knowledgeable about guns I
don't think that's a bad thing
but this is not about our obsession with
guns
this is about our obsession with solving
problems with a gun
it's what it is
you got a problem a gun will fix it you
goddamn right gonna [ __ ] fix it
you don't like this person you don't
like that person you don't like how they
look
you don't like how they dress you don't
like who they love
you don't like that they're not working
hard enough for you at the Walmart
they might make funny they might call
you names
you're down a delusional rabbit hole on
the internet so you want to blame it on
someone else ah gun will fix all that
problem
yeah you got money problems gonna fix it
you got car problems you gotta don't fix
it
you got you you got relationship
problems yeah you goddamn write a gun
will fix it that's the [ __ ] gun
culture in this country
you got a problem gonna fix it
and there's always dead bodies at the
other end of the fixing
why
how do you think we had the body count
stacked up like we got
people aren't shooting [ __ ] targets
at a range
to fix their problems
whatever the problem may be
it's all delusion
all of it
whether it be hatred bigotry
or just plain [ __ ] lunacy and
stupidity
what are we gonna do about it [ __ ]
nothing
not a goddamn thing
nope
numb to it
oh [ __ ] you hear some guy shot killed
seven people at Walmart
he's a manager walked into the
into the lunchroom
started killing him well God damn
that's the attitude
because you're not surprised that
someone's trying to fix a problem with a
[ __ ] gun
how do you think we got here
you give Americans enough [ __ ]
decades
with weapons of war
handguns assault rifles
automatic guns
semi-automatic guns
given and you give them several decades
without providing any kind of access to
Mental Health
you [ __ ] step on their necks at every
[ __ ] every [ __ ] time we talk about
tax policy or wage equality
you get them through a couple [ __ ]
recessions
really really dig in on their anxiety
you know what I mean
and then what you do then what you do is
blame it on other people
blame your [ __ ] on other people you know
what I mean
you know people coming across border
them damn Muslims coming over here
what about those what about those trans
people
blame it on the people you work with
because God damn you know they're
[ __ ]
folks we got a gun problem
but it's a gun culture problem
you blame it on Mental Health you can
blame it on all kinds this person was a
crazy person with a lunatic
of course they were
what are you what the [ __ ] do you think
an absolute sane stable person
picks up a weapon and goes and starts to
kill other human beings
for for just uh well just just sport
no of course they're [ __ ] lunatics
that's why we need to get rid of the
component of the [ __ ] gun
it's the gun
people are gonna have people are always
going to have mental health problems
I mean we need to address this problem
quickly I mean quickly this Mental
Health Access to mental health care
we really need to address that problem
it's not going to happen
they again Republicans give a [ __ ] about
your access
to [ __ ] mental health care as much as
they care about restricting access to
the people who need mental health care
to guns
and it's all because it's profitable for
the gun manufacturers over the last week
we've had seven mass shootings I think
in seven [ __ ] days
gun manufacturers are happy as a lark
I bet they're sitting in [ __ ] rooms
right now as we're talking and they're
like this is great man you should see
the numbers today
after that shooting at Walmart God damn
every single Walmart employee is going
to buy them a damn gun
to take take to take to work with him
they're [ __ ] excited
they're excited this morning
right Wingers we're excited when Club Q
got shot up
[ __ ] Tim Pooh was like well [ __ ]
they didn't shoot enough of them
basically
that [ __ ] piece of trash
this is where we're at though and you
know it they know it everybody knows it
everybody knows that we got a gun
problem and the and the and the other
problem we got is the only way to solve
a problem is with a gun in this country
that's it
and most of it's white gun culture to be
quite honest with you because let me
tell you something
if every black person in this country
went and bought a semi-automatic rifle
and started walking in the streets with
them by God you'd have some [ __ ] gun
control fast
people
don't get it [ __ ] twisted
these are just cold hard facts you may
not like to hear them
it's what it is
that's why I come here right
every day
you thought this show is going to be all
happy go lucky for Thanksgiving I wish
it was
but us
people out here walking around in this
country are not safe from each other
we're not
um
because the minute you become a problem
the minute you become a problem
there's a gun solution for you
notice Hat's always got the gun you know
as I ever want every single [ __ ]
thing it's always there's gun involved
there's always gun
always
there's never a mass fist fighting right
Mass stabbings no
a mass spooning
a mass baseball bat
swinger
nope
it's gone
more importantly it's our culture around
the [ __ ]
and they got no new video games
and ain't got nothing to do with mental
health or lunatics or people who are
crazy there's a lot of [ __ ] people
who are crazy that aren't going out
getting guns killing people
a lot
I know a lot of people who are [ __ ]
off their rocker they ain't going out
shooting people not every [ __ ] person
that has a mental health problem is a
mass shooter just like just like not
every single member of the LGBT
community is a groomer Tim Poole you
[ __ ] vile pieces [ __ ]
foreign
you're just going to go on about your
way
I mean you know you might talk about it
over Thanksgiving dinner
a little bit here a little bit there
Maybe
just talk about how good the gravy
tastes
whether you like the lumps in the mashed
potatoes or you don't want the lumps in
the mashed potatoes
is the turkey dry
maybe you will maybe you won't
we got to start having these National
conversations though it is a thing that
has to happen
and it is the [ __ ] guns
we've done this [ __ ] before
we have done this before we had an
assault weapons ban it [ __ ] worked
70 percent
70 percent less mass shootings
some would say well Tony there's just
too many guns now
well that may have been their intent on
making sure that that ban was lifted
ever think about that
we gotta pluck our heads out of our
asses though
it's sad
it's sad that you're not safe anywhere
you go into a [ __ ] public building
now your first thought is which door am
I going to run out of
when some [ __ ] comes in here
with a gun
you do that
do you do that when you go into a
[ __ ] building
especially when there's a lot of people
you're like all right I'm gonna scope
out the exits here
they're gonna have to start building
Walmart break rooms now
with exits
in case someone comes in to start
shooting them
think about that we're we are we are we
are we are designing architecture in
this country buildings
to make sure if someone comes in with a
[ __ ] gun
for years we've we've had you know a
fire safe electrical systems engineered
sprinkler systems in case of a fire
we engineer buildings in different parts
of the country for wind and weight load
in case there's a tornado or a hurricane
depending on where you're at
in some parts of the country they have
foundations
then make sure to in case there's an
earthquake that the building doesn't
kill a bunch of people and now we have
to design buildings because of guns
we cannot we cannot prevent
snow load
we cannot prevent wind load on a
building
we cannot
prevent earthquakes
we don't have to design buildings around
mass shootings
schools hospitals grocery stores
Walmarts the like
we do not have to do this [ __ ]
we can tell them to [ __ ] off
we can and I I believe gen Z is going to
um
yep
yeah remember this [ __ ] generation
grew up
having drills hiding underneath desk
wearing book backpacks
telling them how to fight
someone who's carrying a [ __ ] rifle
you don't think this generation is
highly aware
that guns are the [ __ ] problem you
don't think come on
see you [ __ ] two-way Bros you gun
nuts you better get to the table fast
you better get to the table and start
having a conversation we have to have a
national conversation about this we we
got to stop not politicizing this [ __ ]
oh
thoughts and prayers [ __ ] your top
thoughts and prayers stick those
thoughts and prayers straight up your
[ __ ] ass
anyone who says anything about prayers
at this point about a shooting can [ __ ]
off
you ain't worth the goddamn thing you
ain't worth the [ __ ]
you should be mad you should be pissed
[ __ ] your God [ __ ] your prayers [ __ ]
your thoughts he ain't doing [ __ ] for
you not in this moment not for this
problem the only way to fix it is us the
people
that's it
it's us we are the [ __ ] solution to
this problem
that's why the Republicans are scared of
democracy
because they're donors over at the NRA
are terrified of democracy terrified of
it
they don't want you to vote they want
you to kill people
that's good for gun sales voting isn't
good for gun sales what does voting have
to do with gun sales
you being scared of being shot by a gun
and having to go buy one and then that's
good for [ __ ] profit
for gun manufacturers
I was in Middle School when Columbine
happened
and everyone kind of looks at Columbine
as a turning point
in this country
with guns
and there's footage of Wayne lapay Air
you know the fraudster with the NRA
as as all Republicans or fraudsters
Wayne lopayer going to Congress
talking about how we need more
control on guns more gun reform
soon after that the NRA and Wayne
LaPierre
decided you know what this mass shooting
thing it isn't so bad for business so
we're going to be for the mass shootings
we're going to make sure people can
actually access the guns that make make
mass shootings even more horrifying
that's what we're gonna do
instead of my automatic rifles [ __ ] yeah
let's do that that makes it way more
terrifying
and I make way more people buy way more
against
they learned very quickly
and this is what we're up against
handful of families who manufacture
that's what it is a handful of families
who manufacture guns in this country
who had the Republican Party by the
short and curlies with their [ __ ]
money
ain't got nothing to do with guns it's
got everything doing money
on the politics side right
the reality is though
that we're the collateral damage
We the People
I wanted to talk about something
different
and we're going to talk about Trump and
his tax returns today and how this
[ __ ] is absolutely cooked
you've seen the uh the title today
you like the thumbnail the Trump turkey
cooked
oh boy he's [ __ ]
he's fat oh Betty not going well he had
a really [ __ ] horrible day yesterday
and Grandpa poopy pants is over on fraud
social
posting more Q Anon garbage of course
the Cheeto dusk Q anoner is everyone I
hope you have a a great Thanksgiving I
really do I'm probably gonna say this
three or four times today but you know I
repeat myself I repeat myself and I
repeat myself but I hope you have a
great Thanksgiving
um we as you know we we are going to
take a four day weekend
so we will not have a show tomorrow or
Friday we will not have a bonehead of
the week show we're going to do a poll
for you tomorrow and maybe we'll do
something special for Thanksgiving for
you guys to
um actually select a bonehead of the
week so we'll do a poll and then and
then Gabe will make the little animation
and she goes like you know the race
nothing
so we'll we'll do the bonehead of the
week poll this week but we actually
won't have a show on Friday
so and I appreciate everyone uh sticking
with us this week even though it's
holiday weekend I I hope you guys are
traveling safe
um
I'm telling you wear your mask out there
I was sick over the weekend I'm still
trying to get over it I'm feeling much
better today I'm still a little cloudy
from all the you know the medicine they
can't take the for the drainage and
stuff shits make you cloudy
but I'm feeling much better my voice is
getting back to a better situation too
but I hope you guys have a safe uh and
healthy
holiday weekend
um I hope when you run into your crazy
relatives
who don't have opinions they hold stupid
delusional beliefs that you're able to
have a conversation with them maybe just
maybe maybe just maybe make them think a
time or two
um during this holiday weekend about how
ignorant
those beliefs that they hold are
and eat some turkey in the meantime eat
some turkey watch some football take a
nap that sort of thing
um and just be safe that's the main
thing be safe
just make it back home alive
Jesus Christ everyone stick around we're
gonna be right back right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears Tammy
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ]
up we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
someone on Twitch says they have a slim
jim
PTSD I have to tell you I tried to
finish the uh slim jim oh that thing
from yesterday
it's a tortilla with Slim Jims and then
easy cheese on it
at first you know I guess it was all
right but then I I tried to eat more of
it oh my God worst
Texas Paul is a [ __ ] liar he totally
he totally lied to me
he totally lied to me I think he's just
trying to get me to eat it
that thing was nasty [ __ ] nasty
ruined the tortilla ruined the [ __ ]
Slim Jim and ruined the easy cheese let
me see if I can get my
co-host on here we're gonna have Rachel
bittickoffer here at the top of the
excuse me if I have to mute a few times
I'm still I'm still this cough is still
lingering a bit not a lot just a bit
depending on how much
you know craziness I got going on let's
uh let's see if Gabe Sanchez is gonna
he's gonna join us but Rachel bidikoffer
is going to join us at the top of the
hour
we're gonna ask Rachel about um
the midterm after
damn thanks for hanging with me with
through some of these coughing pits but
Rachel bittickoffer is going to come on
and give us uh her take on the house
and if Kevin McCarthy's gonna be the
speaker maybe I'm going to ask her that
um so if you guys get some questions for
Rachel put them in the um put them in
the chat there we'll see if we can Point
them out get Rachel
um I I you know Rachel bittickoff or Dr
Rachel bittickoffer is my favorite
political strategist
and she's a master of messaging
absolute master
so I wanted her
to come on today
for the Thanksgiving chill because she's
just one of my favorites
of all time
great friend of mine Dr Rachel
bittickoffer so
um if anyone hasn't heard or or know who
Dr Rachel bittick offer is you're
missing out
totally you're missing out
um she likes to throw around the F-bomb
which is like on positive
um she holds no punches positive
she doesn't care about your [ __ ]
feelings
rather you rather something that she
says makes you feel good or not it's
just it's just pure cold hard facts
positive
and sit
oh man these guys really are projecting
we got a lot of Q and owners in the chat
today
a lot of Q anoner's in the chat over on
Facebook oh my God Jeremy Johnson's back
they can't stop talking about they can't
stop [ __ ] talking about
pedophiles these [ __ ] these
projection these Q Anon projectionists
or something
Jesus Christ they are absolutely
obsessed
obsessed
with children it is [ __ ] weird you
people are [ __ ] weird
you you [ __ ] really have some
sort of [ __ ]
screw loose
no one's running around thinking
everybody's pedophiles you [ __ ]
weirdos
the majority of people do not do not do
not sit around and think about
pedophilia like you people do like Matt
Walsh's of the world where they're
absolutely obsessed they're on they're
in the Facebook chat
I don't know maybe we'll ban them yeah
maybe maybe they're kind of fun though
to watch them
[ __ ]
weirdos man weirdos they just absolutely
[ __ ] obsessed
they can't think about anything else I
told you I think it was last week or the
week before
I got into a Twitter space with a bunch
of right Wingers
and they were talking about [ __ ]
dicks like like they couldn't stop
talking about [ __ ] penis
like they just couldn't stop talking
about it we were talking about banning
books and they asked me about The
Adventures of Huckleberry Flynn and To
Kill a Mockingbird those two books about
banning them
and rather the left should ban them
because of the n-word and I was trying
to give my opinion and these people kept
talking about oh wieners and jacking off
and
I was like what the [ __ ] are you people
talking about you people are
you need to [ __ ] take a break from
Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro and Tucker
Carlson you really need to take reprieve
from this crazy [ __ ] you people
you people are [ __ ] just absolutely
clouded
with [ __ ] dreams of pedophilia it is
[ __ ] weird I I don't know of a time
in this country
where this was more prominent in a
movement like this especially in the
Christian Movement where there's more
goddamn pastors right now right-wing
pastors that are being caught with child
porn and molesting children than ever
before
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[ __ ]
stop having your [ __ ] mind on
children it's [ __ ] weird and you're
sexualizing them in your mind when
you're when you're absolutely thinking
that everyone is a pedophile you are
doing that it is in your mind
you have it in your mind that idea lives
in your brain that's the problem that
you have
like Matt Walsh
talking about the sexuality of children
blah blah blah blah blah
dude the reason why it seems so
prominent is because you can't stop
thinking about it you can't stop
doing the whole bathroom genitalia thing
that's not a thing it's really not I
know it feels good
to project your problems and your your
[ __ ] [ __ ] up thoughts onto other
people
but it's it's not gonna go anywhere
it's only going to get you in more and
more trouble
and really it's [ __ ] dangerous Jesus
Christ
whoosh
whoosh ow look here Dustin and on
Facebook look at this [ __ ] idiot
Dustin says who's Matt Walsh this is
this is more to the point Dustin
you're oh baby I can't believe you just
set this up on the T for me thank you so
much Dustin I appreciate it it's almost
like fake Gabe
is not the top of the Heap anymore
listen up [ __ ]
Dustin is either acting like he doesn't
know who Matt Walsh is or doesn't know
that he is absolutely coming in this
chat and spewing the garbage that Matt
Walsh sells no [ __ ] clue he has no
idea no idea that Matt Walsh's lies live
in his head
that's how [ __ ] delusional Dustin is
here
that's how [ __ ] dumb Dustin is this
is how misinformation Works Dustin [ __ ]
Justin Jesus Christ you couldn't come
with a [ __ ]
more stereotypical name could you Dustin
the reason why misinformation works so
well is you don't have to know where it
comes from
it just has to suit your fancy
it has to give you a good feeling about
your predisposed beliefs
that makes everything in the world that
is your problem not your fault someone
else's
and Matt Walsh lives deep inside your
[ __ ] head rather you know who he is
or not
and I I'm guessing he does know who he
is you know Destiny you're playing
[ __ ] dumb
his [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] guy
whoosh whoosh
these people are [ __ ] sick
absolute Obsession absolute obsession
mm-hmm
you know what a lot of people have been
um going to uh
these memes where
and I I I I don't know exactly what it's
called it's it's uh like beauty pageants
they had a show about it at one point
where where they they do like little
girls and they get them all dressed up
like um is it John John benay Ramsey
is it is that the um I think that and
I'm not sure what it is but I don't
think it's Beauty Pages what the hell is
this stuff called
but they have they have a lot of memes
out there of these girls being dressed
up
as adult women right
right like
pageants and the mighty Librarians it
says pageants they are pageants
uh but they're they're for little girls
and they're basically you know dressing
them up as adult
women making them dance around sing
dance
that's not grooming
and that's not that's not gender
affirming at all
just like hair plugs
and all kinds of [ __ ] all kinds of
plastic surgery that people get done on
themselves to affirm their gender like
Elon Musk
[ __ ] has hair plugs like a
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] that
guy has hair plugs
that [ __ ] ain't real he had something
done
that's gender affirming surgery
you're having a surgery to make you look
more like
you want to look as a man
how don't you [ __ ] know this
your orange Mussolini Jesus
guys his hair
puts on [ __ ] makeup
where's a girdle an oversized suit and
lifts in his shoes so he appears taller
he's basically in Trump drag
how don't you [ __ ] know this
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with your your
[ __ ] minds
you people
have turned your brains into liquid [ __ ]
with reading all this garbage on the
internet stop
whoosh
and we wonder why
we wonder why
lunatics
who have easy access guns go solve their
problems with them hmm
we're going to do the [ __ ] list Roundup
here I don't know um
I don't know if
Gabe Sanchez and I don't see him yet but
let's do this let's go to the Tweety
tweets and the trendy Trends while it
still exists oh I got an Elon yeah
I'm not sure if I want to talk about
this but I got an Elon Musk
um
tweet I want to show you let's start the
countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Happy Thanksgiving or Thanksgiving
Eve I guess yeah we're not gonna be on
the air but we're gonna have Rachel
bittick offer on here in probably about
20 minutes she's happy pretty
Thanksgiving Happy pre and thanks
Thanksgiving Eve I don't know what it is
yeah I don't know I just wrote I just
said happy thing a happy turkey day on
the board here on your happy turkey day
exactly
that's pretty good right yeah that was
pretty good it's pretty good yeah it was
like good that was soundboard ready to
go
that's what a female sounds like I don't
know if you know that you know last year
our Thanksgiving we had uh Austin Archer
on and you guys did not know that
turkeys had beards
yeah didn't know that that was a year
ago that's that was a year ago that is
nuts yeah you didn't know that turkeys
had beards they do have beards it's that
little
yeah I didn't know that's what it was I
thought I thought it was called
something else but I don't know that's a
beard that's a beard I mean not like a
beard you know I mean yeah yeah you had
a grill it's been like a nerd yeah beard
yeah yeah neck beard but yeah they have
they have beards I I grew up around a
lot of
turkeys on the farm we didn't own any
turkeys no I somehow showed up well I
mean we have wild turkeys running around
all over the place it was a farm yeah
and but but but I did go to Turkey barns
we'd clean out turkey barns where they'd
raise domestic turkeys made um they'd
you know have big contracts with
companies like Cargill and stuff there
was a lot of turkey barns around the
community that I lived there's a lot of
turkey barns smells like turkey [ __ ] to
be quite honest but oh
it's a hell of a hell of a living uh to
make a living that way farming turkeys
yeah but so I've seen a lot of turkeys
I've seen them in the wild before yeah
yeah just like wandering and I was like
the turkeys are completely different
they look different like the ones you
eat yeah not the same yeah but but a
wild turkey you know it's kind of
interesting to watch
to watch them I never really liked to
hunt
yeah a lot of different reasons it was
way too early and way too [ __ ] cold
and and you had to be way too [ __ ]
quiet
and that was are you saying are you
saying that I'm not capable of being
quiet is that no no not at all yeah yeah
but also no the reason is because so
when I was a kid I used to go with my
cousin and my uncle during Thanksgiving
whenever we go over there you guys go
turkey hunting uh no no deer hunting oh
okay I guess yeah so it would be you
know wake up at like I don't know like
the [ __ ] at 4am right get the big orange
jumpsuit son get the vest done got the
heat warmers it's got little hand
packets got my like you know two beanies
a hoodie on everything everything
because it's a [ __ ] coolest [ __ ]
because we're up up in Upper Wisconsin
so it's so [ __ ] cold so
we go out and
uh we just have to wait in the watch box
right and we just hang out the whole day
couldn't make a Peep had to sit there
and as a kid who's like 11 12 13 like my
mind is already racing on other things
right like I'm like oh the guy do this I
can do that Michael's like calm the [ __ ]
down if you make any noise you have ADHD
too don't you yeah so it's like you put
me in a in a box in a tree like you know
it's not gonna go well because I'm gonna
[ __ ] find something to pass the time
I'm gonna [ __ ]
drum on like the the wall stuff this
little [ __ ] tree cabin right
it's I don't know I mean it was it was
fun
it's a good memories yeah I mean like
when you would track like when we would
go and we'd like try to track some down
like go actually out later in the day
and then go around and try to find them
that was more fun but sitting in them
yeah sitting in a box all day that just
waiting for one to walk by so you can
shoot it see I never I never got the
whole you know just shooting an animal
like well yeah yeah I mean I didn't I
didn't enjoy I thought you hit them with
cars you know like well that's you hit
him with the car and you're like look at
look at this 10 point buck I got on you
know book
um I have a story when I was a kid and
this is probably the last time that
anyone took me deer hunting I was really
young and I got all bundled up like you
said in the [ __ ] you know the
overalls and and we had these little
wood like folding benches
and we're sitting at the edge of a of a
like a plot you know of a food plot
sitting there and I fell asleep it's
early I'm all bundled up and warm it's
cold outside I fell asleep and my dad
kind of elbows me he's like hey hey
there's a deer and I said I'm sleeping
okay
I have never seen a [ __ ] deer before
like come on I've seen the deer what do
I give a [ __ ] I mean we used to we used
to have deer there would go my
grandparents owned a a bit of land in
Wisconsin as well and
uh we would always every winter like
there were things that we do we put uh
he had this like contraption that he
built which was like uh basically was
like a wind it was like a spin wheel
yeah but they had we he would put on uh
he would screw on uh uh corn
on the ends right so he would like he
had a stick and then they had a screw
and then he screwed in and it was like
probably like
10 or 8 ends of this and it was meant
for the squirrels so the squirrels would
like ride this thing all day long eating
the [ __ ] corn and then leaving but
then we'd also put out like salt blocks
for the deer to come out and lick so
then we could watch the back window and
be like oh yeah there's a deer that's so
cool so as a kid it was fun uh I just
remember doing that with my grandparents
like during during the holidays during
like Thanksgiving Christmas time would
put out the salt blocks and watch the
deer come through the back like woods
and then uh and just hang out well the
Missouri conservation department has um
uh close to our houses where they had
their big offices and stuff
and they have like a a nature center and
a nature trail
um but so we go up there and we'll walk
with the family and there's a lot of
wildlife there so there's a lot of wild
turkey and deer and so you know I like
to watch them and I want to shoot them
though yeah yeah but I I but we do you
know there is um you know this we're
talking about guns this morning because
more mass shootings uh this uh Walmart
in Virginia
um and now uh hunting with guns because
when I was a kid that's that was the
talk around guns right it was like
they're for hunting right you're for
hunting and and there's actually for
people out there that don't know that
that is an actual really
um logical purpose for it because you
have to keep the population down of
some wild animals in some areas and the
reason why because they can cause a lot
of property damage right I mean like I
was talking here like cars well not only
that but like in Texas you know like uh
I I know friends who have talked and
actually verified this with Texas ball
is there's a wild hog right issue there
are millions of wildlife they breed like
[ __ ] crazy and their their skin is
like bulletproof vest so trying to get
through them is usually like I [ __ ]
uh a very high powered rifle but not
only that but in the Bay Area up in
Sacramento uh I just had a buddy who
went up there just a few weekends ago do
the same thing I guess they have a boar
problem as well or a wild hog problem as
well and they just they're very like
they they have to do population control
by hunting to be like yeah we'll give
you more permits to to shoot and remove
these because they're they're ripping
through uh vegetative life and
everything like that that we they're not
net they're not they're not uh
indigenous indigenous or like from this
area so we have to actually uh focus on
on population control right now well
they they do the same thing even um with
or without Firearms like down in Florida
this they have a huge python problem
down in Florida yeah where they're you
know releasing pythons and stuff like
this that aren't indigenous to that
environment and it's
um my wife was showing me a video the
other day where this python had eaten
this entire uh uh uh Gator and like oh
yeah man that's wild down there crazy
ass [ __ ] and that this snake was [ __ ]
huge I mean it was huge it was also
crazy because like you know even if you
watch like smaller snakes you watch them
they're like oh I'm gonna digest or I'm
gonna consume you know a snake that's
like
the size of this pen and then you've got
you know and alligator an egg that's
like the size of this mouse and it just
like completely just
slowly too just like slowly takes over
and then you see this lump and then over
time the lump just breaks down yeah it
is it's crazy to watch crazy well Happy
Thanksgiving everyone um let's uh talk
about turkey net now and what kind of so
so um I've got while we're waiting on uh
doc here I've got um do you have that
um
the video
that Elon Musk [ __ ]
um posted of the hashtag stay woke oh
um
a lot of people probably don't want to
talk about this but I'm going to but
while you're pulling that up I'm gonna
pull up a chip Roy I don't know if you
know chip Roy he's a congressman from
Texas
and he thinks the military is about
blowing [ __ ] up and killing people I'm
not kidding you listen to this [ __ ]
knucklehead because you've got the
leadership the brown of the Department
of Defense who are prioritizing pride
month putting out pictures with rainbow
bullets that they're you know having the
military stand down for a day to focus
on the you know whiteness and the
wokeness and all of the the danger that
they say is appearing which is actually
rather minimal and small and they're
destroying the culture of our military
uh naturally higher positions at the top
level of defense for diversity and
equity which is saying apologize for
your whiteness and promoting your 1619
project we need to end that we need to
refocus our military on what it's
supposed to do which is blow things up
and kill people blow things up and kill
people oh my God you know there's not a
worse way to describe the military than
that yeah like have you ever met someone
who was in the military or had a family
member as a military like so what's the
military about well it's about blowing
[ __ ] up and killing like how many
[ __ ] movies has this guy won
I've got friends who are in the military
one who actually just came back from
being deployed and the only focus he's
like yeah I'm serving my country I've
done several tours but like my only
focus is my family to go back to my my
my wife and my daughters like those are
things that when you're like what's the
military it's like oh I'm I'm serving my
country I'm doing my part I am paying
off blowing [ __ ] up yeah killing people
like what are you that is the last thing
on his mind he's like I'm doing this
service I'm not I don't want to [ __ ]
blow [ __ ] up and kill people I want to
do my time come back to my family go and
deployed again serve my time help people
I don't want to [ __ ] kill people
it's it's Insanity that the that chip
Roy and I'm sure this guy we probably
look it up I'm sure this guy is on the
armed services committee yeah because
everyone's on the [ __ ] armed service
committee literally he's probably on the
arms Services committee and this guy
doesn't understand that there's like a
million things that the military does
before you get to blow [ __ ] up and kill
people well chip Roy is probably also
the same guy who thinks that the
government's coming for his guns and he
needs to build up an Arsenal to protect
himself from a tank right from from from
a thing that would just knock him out or
you know keep in mind
the U.S military has drones where you've
got a guy at the computer [ __ ] you
know counter-struct Counter-Strike Style
just [ __ ] oh yep shoot it down boom
boom boom and you've got a [ __ ]
predator drone no one has to be near you
and then you're there in your little
like home basement little like Arsenal
kind of pile and you're like oh man if
the government [ __ ] tries to
overthrow or or tries to overtake me I'm
gonna overthrow the government with my
[ __ ] rifle and it's like you have no
chance whatsoever you are nowhere
in in any I forget who it was there was
a comedian that was recently talking
about something similar and it was like
let's just have a whole militia against
one guy and that one guy is just like is
this even fair like can I do this
against them if I shoot a military
strike from a drone like that shouldn't
be allowed oh they they shot at me okay
fine you know boom boom speaking of
drone strikes the Twitter's blowing up
this way you want to show the video
first uh I can is that I thought it was
a deleted tweet the second is deleted
tweet so you want to give context to
what's about to happen
okay so click the first link I sent you
okay I thought I thought I thought that
that you were saying that first one's
still up he then came in and deleted
oh so he did he did leave the video up
yeah he the video's still up he hasn't
taken it down let's double down on this
this is Elon Musk video that he took I'm
guessing from his [ __ ] cell phone
um probably or someone else's and he
tweeted founding closet at Twitter
hqfr laugh face laugh face
oh oh and you can see that it's a shirt
that says stay woke
um but let's let's see what kind of work
the hard work that Elon Musk is doing
over there Twitter here we are uh at the
at the March thing and there's an entire
entire closet full of secret closet of
hashtag woke the t-shirts
oh that what number one okay there's a
lot of context to this here like that
some people didn't realize just from the
plain simple fact of the video but when
you actually go look at the hashtag and
know what the hashtag was about and why
that [ __ ] was there then you start to go
whoa
racist [ __ ] now I don't know if
Elon knew that kind of [ __ ] I have no
idea if this well I mean you know
apartheid baby wow you know it is it
makes like I said Elon Musk is showing
his true color white and is true uh
Aaron my post woke up to DM's alerting
me to this tweet Elon posted and deleted
overnight suffice to say yikes so but
wait Aaron's saying he deleted it RR is
it this one here no no that one okay so
so he put in a thread yeah another tweet
so he put this tweet and then also
linked to the doj
uh uh yeah yeah yeah yeah I see I seen
that one now the doj article is about
Michael Brown and Ferguson correct okay
so he uh Elon tweets here stay woke
shirts stem from the Ferguson protest
Obama's own doj and proved this and
exonerated cop quote hands up don't
shoot was made up the whole thing was
fiction oh [ __ ] yeah
now I last night I actually text this to
you did you see this before I text it to
you no no I sent the other one
because it was it was like right after
it happened when he yeah he sent this
when he sent this tweet out with the
video and I was like oh [ __ ] because I
read almost immediately I read what
state hashtag stay woke what that
hashtag was and it was tied to Mike
Brown
yeah and so if you clicked it if you if
you click the next link yeah okay that's
the one that you sent me last night
which was giving context because he was
like hey just so you know
I
laughing about this is not the take that
you think it is right right owning the
[ __ ] Libs right because they think
this is some kind of libtard hashtag
exactly that's not what this is
this was BLM this was during the
Ferguson
uh when Mike Brown was killed by a cop
um Mac Orion Mack has it here Elon Musk
has said he's about context on tweets
now he's not about anything yeah well
Elon Musk is about Elon Musk right he
[ __ ] says [ __ ] that he's never gonna
[ __ ] deliver on so here's context for
these shirts they came from Twitter's
black employee Resource Group oh Jesus
and we're a polar uh popularized by at
Jack which is Jack Dorsey the former CEO
who wore a version around the
conferences to support the group uh in
quote Aaron in
um frames and was sometimes ridiculed
for it
so that's the context of this and it
goes on uh it gives more context for
this
I'm not going to read it all but I'll
retweet it in case you want to go look
at this thread
um
but the longer the short of it is now
rather Elon realized this or not
um obviously well he realized it enough
to know that to tweets the first time
was fine but the second time was not
okay and if you go back to that tweet
which one
the one that I just sent you the Ryan
Mack yeah yeah okay
so uh you've also got that [ __ ]
David sacks now for people who don't
know who David Sachs is is this this guy
here yeah yeah
where yeah yep yeah
uh uh so he's from the bit well he's a
entrepreneur in the Bay Area and he's a
goddamn sociopath uh I've had friends
who have worked at companies that he's
you know been at Yammer and uh so him
and Elon get along really well oh yeah
yeah well they have connections well I
mean like they both worked at PayPal
so
it's a
the guy is you know he was the CEO of
zenefits I've cut [ __ ] air you want
it um okay uh so zenefits yeah zenefits
it's a it's an HR program uh software
that companies use to uh handle all of
their you know payroll benefits
anyway
but it sounds like it sounds like some
kind of like friendship at where you
[ __ ] your friends like Friends with
Benefits kind of thing yeah yeah I don't
know here's the here's the I'll give you
the tldr on this zenefits is a company I
know because I knew people who worked
there uh the former CEO of that company
which sax took over as like interim CEO
got in trouble because they were what
they had to do is everyone had to get
licensed and regulated to sell these
products basically to sell insurance
because that's what we're doing you're
selling health insurance and what they
were doing was they were uh you could
read all about if you look up zenefits
there's a buzzfeed expose on it really
goes into it and exposes how these
people were not not only were they just
like debaterous employees and crazy
parties condoms on the railings just
insane stuff but also they were they
were cheating and getting their
insurance license because they were
using a macros program to keep the the
computer are active right move the mouse
every once in a while on the computer
automatically no I see like when your
work from home kind of thing exactly so
it doesn't make you look inactive
because you have a certain amount of
time that you have to stay on these
programs to learn the actual like
insurance policies that so you can sell
them anyway it's a crazy thing I
recommend that people go look it up
zenefits BuzzFeed expose that'll pretty
much get to it but Saks is a guy who
took over sax is a terrible [ __ ]
person and he's a [ __ ] sociopath well
I know from the Bay Area not not not
surprising that his last name is Saks so
go give balls sex a read there everyone
we're gonna have a ride Dr Rachel
bittagova on she's going to give us an
update on midterms and messaging and
what it means that the America First
Nazi party is now taking over the House
of Representatives and if she believes
I'm gonna ask her if she believes Kevin
McCarthy will be the Speaker of the
House everyone stick around we'll be
right back with Dr Rachel whitakoffer
right after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
the show special guest
my great friend the best political
strategist
in this country
hands down
no way to dispute them at all Dr Rachel
benicoffer doc how are you oh look I got
them I got the banner wrong
that's not the one there we go Dr Rachel
bittickoffer how are you dig it on
[ __ ] channel in the Unabomber what's
up oh my God you are aren't you
how how is your Thanksgiving week so far
are you gonna have a great Thanksgiving
are you planning on the turkey the ham
the taters oh man you're so lucky I
moved home and like I have good friends
here that know the old Rachel the old
Rachel didn't cook okay the old Rachel
would sit there and watch the football
with the men's folks on the couch while
the ladies cooked us up a meal and my
friend is taking this year off because
she's getting her house redone so I
actually I'll have to have to say I I
was kind of just gonna largely stumble
and ignore Thanksgiving because there's
no way I'm reaching my hand into a
turkey's ass okay that's not gonna
happen and uh somebody kicked me down a
couple really Choice prime rib steaks or
dry rub I mean I'm I'm pretty I'm pretty
stoked dude be honest with you I didn't
know if you're gonna go like to the
Denny's or what no no I have a prime rib
uh um rib eye ribeye steak you know so I
think I'm just going to shock tradition
this year entirely like I I mean I am a
turkey fan and I want a turkey but my
mom can't cook me one now because I'm
back on the west coast my friends can't
cook me one because they're remodeling
the house so I'm gonna go with some
ribeye dude that's great sounds awesome
how about you guys
what are you guys I'm I'm going over to
uh my girlfriend's uh sister and
brother-in-law's house and we're just
gonna order Chinese food and then we're
gonna hang out and just watch dumb
Christmas movies I think is the plan of
what's going to eat Chinese on
Thanksgiving one must watch The
Christmas Store in the bumpers yeah yeah
there's also yeah and there's also the
Christmas story sequel that just came
out on HBO Max which I'm curious how
that is but they just sent me that [ __ ]
you know I mean so like I I won't call
it blasphemy because it's not like a
remake okay The Karate Kid the Red Dawn
remakes that shit's blasphemy all right
so I won't even consider watching
blasphemy but a follow-up to the
Christmas story I'll let you guys tell
me whether I should watch it all right
well I'll do I'll do my own research
this week
yeah and then Friday we've just Gabe
your sense of humor our respect so
[ __ ] much that if you told me it was
good I believe you and most people that
would not believe
that is a lot of pressure but I
appreciate that that level of uh of
Mayor from you but then and then on
Friday we just have a bigger kind of
like family get-together with more
people and that's more traditional
that's the truth that's the mashed
potatoes the [ __ ] uh you know sweet
potatoes it's everything the pie is out
the [ __ ] wazoo
I'm not gonna travel either I'm gonna
get wasted tonight I'm gonna get there
you go I'm gonna get [ __ ] drunk
tonight and then tomorrow uh evening
um I think uh some my mom and dad my
mom's gonna make she's gonna stick her
hand in the turkey's ass
turkey is what you need through
Thanksgiving you know
some there's a few years there that we
tried to burn down the house and we did
the deep fryer we did that we never
caught we never caught anything on fire
we never had the fryer that caught on
fire but were you were you 20 yards away
from the house or were you next time oh
hell no we were we parked at night
hell yeah yeah
one year we put it in the garage because
it's so damn windy we couldn't keep it
it up so we had we have like cardboard
stacked up around there we're right next
man
we didn't get [ __ ] just throw it in a
barrel you know the house is insured I
think you know what are you gonna do
anything that's why that's like the
number one thing that that the people
get their house count on fire on yeah
I'm pretty sure like deep frying turkey
is why they invented [ __ ] home
insurance Tony yeah
we deep-fried a few turkeys in our day
speaking of turkeys
uh Rachel is Kevin McCarthy going to be
the speaker of the house here what's
your bet here do you think this
[ __ ] is going to be speaker I've
always been at the like 50 probability
mark on a McCarthy speakership right
because I I mean I I you know not always
I would say I I would only after row and
I and when I realized negative
partisanship strategy plus Roe was going
to give us a real chance to throw it
this Red Wave right then I started
thinking well how could he get these
votes and I was pretty sure Republicans
could still win control of the house
because it's just they were literally
set up it was almost impossible to hold
a house majority of the cycle
um so I kind of kind of been thinking
about a scenario that we see now for a
while in my brain thingy and that was
that that they would take control but it
would be on such a terror I mean we have
never seen a House of Representatives
that we're about to see like this is
going to be a total clown [ __ ] show
hey hey hey hey easy easy you're gonna
offend clown shows okay okay you're
gonna I will offend clown shows because
clown shows actually have beginning
middle and able to do things that we're
not going to see that at all out of this
house caucus and I love that it's dates
of course it's going to be Gates and oh
I just love it so you know I mean the
point of the matter is this they have to
pick someone or they do elect a Democrat
or someone else like our our person like
they have to agree it's it's okay 435
members on the floor and the reason why
the majority party always wins the
speakership role is because they have
more votes right but if you have five
you know a five vote threshold between
the opposition party you need every
[ __ ] one episode
when you start subtracting them it goes
quick all right so um you know I really
do think that there's there they
it would be suicidal it's almost incon
incomprehensible that a party in that
scenario could not finally find a
[ __ ] way to pick one person okay but
if any party could do it folks I'm here
to tell you it's this one because
because we have these new the majority
makers from these New York districts and
other places
their needs are usually what the
speakership is designed to serve
okay because you've got to keep the
majority right right and Kevin McCarthy
cannot do that for them he cannot do
that for them and you know it already
because the agenda has been announced
and what's the agenda it's not inflation
it's not crime it's not immigration it's
Hunter Biden's laptop right which is you
know why we're talking about strategic
mock real sure so
um you know it it he can't Square this
needle and John Boehner when he needed
to get [ __ ] done I don't know who was on
TV last night reminded me of this [ __ ]
but it's true she had to whip the votes
of Pelosi okay he had to go Pelosi to go
get him 20 or 30 sane Democrats to put
[ __ ] together and that was 10 years ago
Dude this house Freedom caucus thing has
grown from tea party wave 10 wave one
which ushered in like 30 or 40 of these
people it is now the center of gravity
it controls the caucus it controls
everything but why why are we still
calling it the freedom caucus why aren't
we calling it The Q Anon caucus
and listen I know that like in the in
the bubble of especially like
Progressive minded media
meeting like uh q a and stuff
they are good and stuff but at the end
of the day for the broader electorate we
want to keep [ __ ] simple and repetitious
so I always like to say the the research
and the strategy evolved over the course
of the 22 cycle to tell us that we
should call the Mago Republicans and
that's what I intend to do every chance
I get so it's the Maga caucus it's not
the freedom caucus it's the Maga caucus
and they control the House Majority see
I thought they changed from Maga to
magaga and then it was make America
grotesque and gross again
I just I I love the fact that you know
even from the get-go of 2016 or 2015
when he announced but I think maybe 2016
when the uh the slogan really came in
was like all right we're gonna take it
from Reagan right and we're gonna we're
gonna recycle this and say we're gonna
make it we're gonna make it great again
right and then the question obviously
was like well wait when was America not
great right when was the last time it
was great that we were making it great
again
and then even if you listen to Trump's
speech
uh which I did which is like an hour and
five minutes uh
and he says you know we'll make it great
and glorious again he really keeps
pushing that like glorious Glory part
glory hole
um but at the end of the day he wants to
make it great and glorious again which
if it was great like a golden age as you
described it in 2020 but he wants to
make a great and glorious again
it would make it seem like he never
really made it great to begin with like
he was so bigoted and so much of a [ __ ]
that he [ __ ] the bed and actually made
it the opposite of great right and then
we had to have someone come in like Joe
Biden
and and use that power and use that
influence to actually make things that
work great or propose things that were
great I mean even just yesterday right
he had to extend the student loan
payment because Republicans keep trying
to [ __ ] control the The Good Will of
the presidency to say hey look we're
going to forgive these loans and
Republicans like no no no you can't do
that nice of a thing for Americans
that's crazy I you know Rachel this is
uh great that Gabe brought that up
because they're all running around right
now they're like oh should we be with
Trump should we be with DeSantis they
can't figure out like why gen Z voted
against them like how like how dumb do
you actually have to be because you said
something about mockery like how stupid
do you have to do you have to be that
you convinced your entire base to stoke
fear about about bathrooms genitalia and
gas prices that your first go-to agenda
item is a laptop that's someone owned
that doesn't really even exist
how in the hell do we keep the mockery
up or more should I say how do we not
because I mean you know not every
example is going to work out this way
like so today I'm making fun of Matt
Gates's hair why is it am I making fun
of his hair because number one I'm not
bound by the same liberal rules that you
are your audience or you know whoever
else because I'll say whatever the [ __ ]
I want number two right number two this
is why we love you by the way that's why
we love you by the way I'm pretty
goddamn sure there's a squirrel in it
okay and I feel like we need
we need investigations Tony this is what
we need okay because I think as long as
there's doubt I mean some people are
saying that Matt Gates might have gotten
a squirrel transplanted illegally into
his head and I'm just saying that we
need to investigate this further
I would also go as far as to say that
Matt Gates also might have had elective
plastic surgery
and and got uh he got nicer teeth over
the years so you know just saying some
things were done that were superficial
I'd also like this I'd also like for
someone to grab that guy's laptop too
year old girls that Gates likes to date
one has to have a fabulous squirrel set
of hair you know exactly in front of
Gates's hair what's not about his hair's
appearance in all seriousness right it's
about making fun of how [ __ ] stupid
these people are and so when I say that
we have to mock them especially in terms
of what's coming for these
investigations you know really if I if I
have my choice mockery and strategic
mockery what I'm going to tell you guys
about it's mocking the very premise that
this crime Cabello has any
any right to even say the word
corruption okay
any right to say the word corruption or
politicization of the doj and if we do
not hit them right at the root there and
just invalidate everything right at the
root then it will germinate and it will
become legitimized and the reason why
guys is you can you as soon as we're
willing to have a debate as if this
party cares about corruption in any
[ __ ] way shape or form right then we
have validated their entire argument to
half more than half of the country the
two down half a specialty right all they
hear and see is the exchange and they
figure well these people are willing to
exchange on this topic of CRT it must be
a thing
okay so we must prevent what happened in
21 in Virginia in the closing fall and I
didn't have a lot of influence then but
I have more now than God to tell people
do not [ __ ] do it okay the entire
premise of this committee investigation
[ __ ] that they want to do has to be
mocked it has to be mocked ruthlessly
and endlessly and it has be mocked not
just by people like you and me or even
my Twitter fans or even like the opinion
Pages it has to be mocked by everyone
the reporters covering it the Democratic
house members that are going to be
involved in it the staffers everyone
because these [ __ ] people want to
tell us about corruption are you [ __ ]
kidding me
so we really really need strategic
mockery in this moment and um I will add
one more thing yeah I've been studying
fascism for a while a couple years I
mean you know a lot of different
component parts involved in that in that
immersive study but one of the other
things I took time to go learn about is
okay you know when you've got a mass
psychosis event which is what we have in
the U.S we have a mass psychosis event
it's been 10 15 20 years in the making
we're really 30 years from the talk
radio back but it really became truth
bendy like completely reality
obstructing in the last five or ten
years okay and so we have a minus
psychosis event where about half of the
country does not in any way engage with
or live in the reality of reality okay
there's not two realities there's one
reality and these [ __ ] don't
live right and they and and so you know
I I've spent some time like okay when
you have a situation like this where
you're not talking about individual
maths like or individuals like coaches
you're talking about group or
sociological psychosis what can you do
okay and what I've learned is that the
thing that we have done us up to this
point is the exact [ __ ] opposite
thing to do because as we have had these
substantive rebuttal conversations or
efforts to expose their [ __ ] all we
have done is is help amplify it and make
it look credible right even if you are
and if you you there's a lot of
reporters I think that think their
readers get their snark or their Sly
sarcasm and they don't get it okay so if
you give lip service to how Jim Jordan
is legitimately concerned about Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden profiting from
the prophet from the presidency then you
have done their work for them and that's
why I've been very very vocal in the off
season coming in through the winter
breakthrough of the next you know the
runoff and then of course the um you
know next year getting people to
understand we much will be determined
about our our future right out of the
gate as this new house comes and this
committee starts to evolve and how we
handle ourselves especially the hard
journalists and the Beltway press is
going to determine a lot about how the
public perceives this
I I
holy [ __ ] that was a lot that was a lot
to grab some medicine
man
I was like I was like please please mark
please mock Matt's hair and then it's
like this this [ __ ] master class on
exactly what we need to do as
Republicans we just want people to know
like okay there's a method to the
madness all right like I I am not
actually an [ __ ] person I like to be
nice to people and I certainly don't
want to be mean to Republicans you gotta
punch a Nazi every once in a while you
know what I'm saying I'm verbally I'm
all about punching some Nazis
rhetorically
I'm telling you now like we have to
belittle and Mock and just we just have
to make everybody else in America look
at these people and say I don't want to
be with stupid
well I I think that's really
um a lot that happened with this last
election in the 2022 midterms is people
like you know I'm not exactly Democrat
but I don't want the crazy in charge I
mean you even see in Colorado where
Warren bobert hung on by just a few
hundred votes I mean and it just goes to
show you that every single one of your
votes count like it counts another good
example is Washington's third everyone
thought that one was cooked and the
crazy Joe Kent who was going down to
Mar-A-Lago and running around with Matt
gants and Marjorie Taylor green got his
ass kicked in Washington's third which
has been a republican seat for I don't
know probably the last uh I think it was
like the last last six Cycles or
something
um and I think that's great
but no one no one saw that coming but
you should have because people don't
like stupid and crazy when you're
talking about their [ __ ] like I don't
want you crazies to be in charge of
Social Security and I want you crazies
to be in charge of the economy right and
you're running around talking about
Hunter Biden's laptop who number one it
doesn't exist but number 200 buying is a
private citizen when you're running
around talking about that kind of crazy
and obsessed with that I really don't
want those people in charge of gas
prices at all like right you're not even
coming to reality enough you you also
bring up a good on the on the hunter
Biden thing I thought uh I don't know
who is behind it um but I did see the
stream of people sharing basically
rewriting
the oh this is Hunter Biden doing XYZ
and what they did was they just kept
sharing photos of Jared Kushner Ivanka
Trump Don Jr Eric Trump like all of that
being like Oh yeah I remember when he
took a private flight on this plane and
did this thing I remember when they
violated the Hatch Act I remember when
they did this like all these examples
and putting it right back and being like
there were four years of of uh nepotism
and incompetence so let's really shine a
light on who the real corrupt people
were and I thought that was great and I
was like oh this is great I'm seeing
photos of Ivanka [ __ ] walking on the
runway I see Jared Kushner taking this
private thing I mean even the [ __ ]
Ridiculousness of
it was uh Jared Kushner and Ivanka
wouldn't let their secret service use
their bathroom so they had to rent the
house next door just for the toilet
right like how about money Rachel yeah
but would you let the peasants use your
bathroom for crying out loud I mean come
on my gold toilet
I mean that's but that's that's these
that's that's trumpism in the in the
nutshells that literally the people who
go and cheer him on and wear the stupid
costumes and they're the cult members
they literally wouldn't even let them
[ __ ] in their toilets they won't even
want Secret Service [ __ ] in their
toilets let alone his supporters that
pay for the [ __ ] toilets
is no better dude right so like somebody
put out an article the other day about
how DeSantis is uh not schmoozing enough
at these events for the donor class okay
well that's because he's [ __ ]
terrified that they're going to infect
him with covet and then he's going to go
home and give it to his wife who has
cancer but they're afraid of their own
[ __ ] supporters dude so yeah I we
gotta mock them and the idea that the DZ
Beltway will do what they did with
Clinton and legitimate Benghazi we have
had so many foreign catastrophes on
foreign soil some of them were caused by
Ronald Reagan he blew up I don't know if
people know this he blew up a
[ __ ] passenger airplane that he
thought was Iranian military it was 250
civilians on that [ __ ] thing okay you
want to and and yet we we the the
Beltway accepted the premise that
somehow in DC Hillary Clinton [ __ ] up
this Benghazi thing right and so we
gotta like we've just gotta be as vocal
as we can and as Fierce as we can and
make people understand all right you
cannot set the after six years of the
most flagrant corruption we have ever
seen in this country ever ever seen in
this country that you're gonna let the
Republican Party come out and tell you
that they care about corruption bull
[ __ ] [ __ ] not on my watch it ain't
happening
I couldn't agree more how much time you
got left Rachel I want to talk a little
more uh Thanksgiving with you if you get
a minute no man I'm just chilling dude
right so I gotta I gotta I got a couple
questions for you sorry turkey or ham
which is it oh God [ __ ] ham look at
you get turkey [ __ ] and if you
if you're and if you end up a bachelor
like me and you don't want to stick her
hand in a turkey ass and you don't want
to eat that turkey doesn't have an ass
because it's dry then you eat some steak
for one year okay but you don't have ham
there's no Christmas hams and [ __ ]
oh my God okay so homemade cranberry
sauce or canned cranberry sauce okay I
like I like I'm gonna go with canned and
uh you know that's the only way I guess
yeah [ __ ] life says good jellied
canned cranberry sauce I like the [ __ ]
that's really fake as [ __ ] and it's like
brown gelatinous blobs and cut and slice
okay so is it green beans or green beans
and casseroles oh definitely just green
beans man yeah no creamy I don't like
green bean casserole it's mushroom soup
it's not my fave okay so the next one is
Lumpy mashed potatoes are non-lumps in
your mashed potatoes
you know what I want is I want that real
[ __ ] with no lumps okay
dude she's like because I didn't have
four hours to [ __ ] smooth them all
out you know
so I'll tell you that what I like to do
with my mashed potatoes and this I can't
wait for tomorrow for this I take my
corn and I mix my corn and my mashed
potatoes together oh I like that what's
Ralphie's little brother on Christmas
Story oh yeah yeah mix those two
together oh my God that's one of the my
favorite things with a bunch of
fruitcakes that won't eat anything that
touches anything else you know she got
like dividers on the plate and
everything
yeah I got it I got it well I I hope you
have a safe holiday
um and I know you're I know you're not
going anywhere but um stay safe and uh
send me a picture of the uh the rib eye
that you're oh man I should I should
send you some pics of these [ __ ] rib
eyes they're they're damn they look nice
Tony you're gonna be a little jealous
even if you have your turkey I know I I
may be I may be I may be Dr Rachel
thanks for stop thanks for stopping by
and talking a messaging in turkey with
us Happy Thanksgiving Wednesday before
Thanksgiving show man how could I miss
it dude that's it that's it this is the
show this is the show everyone stick
around we'll be right back thank you Dr
H budokova for joining us today everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
gobble gobble gobble gobble
Thanksgiving week I don't know already
we will not be on the air tomorrow on
Friday we will not have a video version
Elite but we will still do a
Thanksgiving bonehead of the week oh
and then our great co-host and executive
producer Gabe Sanchez will give us a uh
the video what do you call that what is
it I I know you do it every week it's a
race video I don't know
it's just I mean the inspiration was uh
when you're at a when you're at a
carnival and you're shooting the water
guns and you see the horses go by like
what is that called let's see or is it
race Carnival I think it's a horse race
horse race yeah because when we when we
started the bone end of the week because
we wanted to do a weekend thing because
we just had like a Wednesday show
and wanted to do something on the
weekend you're like how can we get the
audience engaged and you had had this
idea of uh of because I say bonehead a
lot so you're like well let's do like a
bonehead something bonehead I'm like
well bone end of the week we can do a
poll and you're like yeah we'll throw it
up on Twitter so that's where that came
from we used to do it on Saturday yeah
or during the weekend I don't remember
do you remember I don't even really
remember this one it was
uh I think it was originally a Saturday
thing yeah I think so it was so long ago
yeah I know
and then we went to every single weekday
we just stuck it in the second hour of
Friday yeah and we didn't learn a few
things about bonehead of the week we
could not do the poll early in the week
yeah yeah yeah because by the time we
got to Friday there were so many more
[ __ ] people that we had to talk about
that it was irrelevant and and and you
put someone like Trump or Marjorie
Taylor green like on the bonehead like
the bone-headed [ __ ] they did on Monday
yeah is it's like the sixth thing on the
list of motion yeah it's bone-headed
[ __ ] that they yeah we definitely
learned we could not post on like a
Tuesday to be like what happened you
know and it's like oh no you haven't
even scratched the surface yet because
even there were times when I'm making
the assets for Friday
yeah Friday morning where people last
minute I'm like oh no this is a
dishonorable mention this is an alpha oh
yeah you're switching you're because we
because that's what we had to do too we
had to add in the two special categories
right so we could actually throw in some
relevant things that happened that
morning and sometimes those things
literally happen right before I finish
and come on the show well you know
sometimes we we even have like the
bonehead you know we got the three
boneheads yeah and the audience will
vote for the bonehead that person will
win right because the [ __ ] they did last
night and then in the morning one of the
other contestants does something way
more bone-headed right and they should
have won but the poll is over like
that's how [ __ ] just yeah ridiculous
these Republicans are it's just
absolutely it's not it's non-stop uh I
it's hilarious uh because they can't
help themselves but we gotta mock them
like right yeah they say or do crazy
fascist
um
perverted things you know and you're
like all right well like I could
probably tell you right now Matt Walsh
is probably gonna be in the running I
mean just based on some of the videos
did you see this Temple thing oh my God
what a [ __ ] scumbag let me show you
this um
is Tim pull tweet here is the uh here's
a screenshot of it
oh [ __ ] I don't know if you guys know
who Temple is if you don't
uh he is he is probably as bad or worse
than Alex Jones to be quite honest with
you
um he says because Tim Poole got really
popular from Ferguson believe it or not
it's really where it's popular and he
does this whole well he was like he was
like a citizen journalist independent
like on the on the street reporting
well right but but he he's the whole I
used to be a liberal type [ __ ] thing
yeah yeah and and Alex Jones came from
um a different generation a different
time but it was really Waco that made
Alex Jones's career but Temple
um says here let me pull this banner
down in this tweet the grimming of
children is not stopping
people are calling for more violence I
do not think legislators will stop The
Grooming
people will not stop calling for
violence so you tell me what happens
next this guy is such a piece of [ __ ]
he's basically now he posted this after
the mass shooting in Club Q in Colorado
Springs now
the thing about the craziest part about
this whole thing is
is that and there's another tweet too
from Temple it's even more disgusting is
that the one you sent here no no that's
a video uh I didn't know if people knew
this but Tim pool's in a cover band oh
okay yeah we'll show that yeah the other
the other
um
tweet that he sent out was just as bad
or more vile
um because he was talking about Club Q
specifically and basically said well
they should have shot more of them let
me see if I can find the [ __ ] thing
it's a
a very bad bad bad bad take to make
right and I'm oh Gabe in the comments is
being like Oh yeah I should have shot
more I love this guy okay um tell me a
republican who actually cares for human
life that in the same breath
will also say ah you know what more of
them should have died
well here it is we shouldn't tolerate
pedophiles grooming kids why in the [ __ ]
I was talking about this earlier because
there was some [ __ ] q and honors
in the comments
that we're talking about why do you
people why are you so [ __ ] obsessed
with pedophilia you people are weird
you're obsessed with it you're obsessed
with you starting to wonder you want an
example of this I sent you those those
screenshots last night so yesterday for
context there's a video of Andrew Tate
right the alpha male right uh wait wait
wait wait is he is he Nick Adams brother
no I'm just kidding you know I don't
know I think they're competing for the
title actually right now okay gotcha but
he he got he was let back onto Twitter
because Elon has is now just approving
people be on his own wow he's in the
[ __ ] box category so of course elon's
gonna let him back which by the way if
people don't know this I guess yesterday
I saw a tweet from him that it was him
justifying why he has now removed this
idea of a Content moderation policy or
or Council he said because advertisers
pulled out
that now he has to be the one that takes
control of the content moderation
Council like he is the content
moderation guzzle which doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense right but anyway the um
the
uh uh that happened and and um sorry I'm
just trying to come back to this ice
right so so yesterday yesterday there
was a video uh that was shared of my
tweet and it was making fun of oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because the whole
thing was like Andrew Tate's bragging
about how he got back on Twitter he's
like had to fly back into the hell State
um you're like this is an old video I'm
like yeah this is three months old so I
call it out a bunch of people cover it
all this [ __ ] happens people start
making funny uh making videos about how
this is funny and all this stuff one of
the videos is shared onto Facebook I'm
tagged in it I go and comment on it and
add a little bit more context to say
yeah this dude is also drinking a 27
bottle
of alcohol right yeah but he wasn't
drinking it because it wasn't opened
right right so regardless of what it was
out on the table I was like 27 bucks
this guy alpha male [ __ ] on a private
jet probably it's a PR it's one of those
fake private jets you can hire for
Instagram influencers
but he's talking about how he's flying
there so I call him out for that it gets
tagged I get tagged in this video on
Instagram I comment that thing and
immediately Within
just [ __ ] moments I get this comment
from this guy uh who looks like he's a
Andrew Tate wannabe shirtless taking a
photo no hair in front of a mirror
already kind of weird so he's he's a
member of Andrew Tate's Hustler
University whatever yeah yeah and my
comment was just about 27 bottle of
alcohol he then went in to talk about
how my mom was transgender which she's
not uh talk about how he wanted to [ __ ]
my mom that's a minor which is [ __ ]
weird he talked about micro penises he
talked about my dad being uh a slum or
something like that he continued to
double down on having sex with my mom
and saying who's your daddy
so I call them out for all this stuff I
was like you're [ __ ] weird man you're
obsessed with Mike so he says he went to
all this after you were like this guy's
drinking nothing booze yeah nothing
about any of those things that were
mentioned I just said Andrew Tate's
drinking a 27 bottle of alcohol that's
all I said literally that was the
comment and he went into my dad my mom
all of this [ __ ] which I was like I
don't know how any of these are related
but the fact that you immediately
default to talking about micro penises
transgender mother my dad having and
then and then also you want to have sex
with my mother who just called a beta
transgender like it doesn't make a lot
of sense you're [ __ ] weird you need
help like some serious help why is that
the first thing that you think of these
people are [ __ ] weird man they're
weird I've been saying it weird well you
remember you remembered I was talking
about this earlier when um we went into
this uh it was a tourist space a couple
weeks ago or some [ __ ] yeah yeah with
these right Wingers it was right it was
right after the midterms because yeah
they lost and they were like oh Trump's
not the orange right or or they call it
right because they were it was like
DeSantis or or yeah yeah or Trump so so
they were talking about banning books
and I was like well I'm I'm not for
Banning books and they were like what
about huckberry Finn and To Kill a
Mockingbird so I was talking about that
and then immediately they were like well
wiener wiener penis penis penis penis
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about and then they went on to list off
the entire list of books they want to
ban and I'm like okay see you just said
that I should be
I should be offended that the left band
Huckleberry Finn and and they kept
correcting me it's the Adventures of
Huckleberry I'm like okay yeah I got it
so Huckleberry Finn To Kill a
Mockingbird I'm supposed to be offended
by that I'm like well I'm not really the
one who's offended
um by what's in the book that's the
point that you're missing is I'm not
offended by what the book says there are
some people who are but the point is is
that their minds went to wieners like
they went to penis it was a weird jump
like we were talking about and they
started calling me a groomer I'm like
what what and what planet does it and me
am I talking about the reason why or why
not Huckleberry Finn or To Kill a
Mockingbird should be banned from a
library because it has the n-word in it
has anything to do with being a groomer
nothing right but their minds went
straight there and that's what Tim
Paul's doing here
and really honestly this tweet here
um may or may not be liable I don't know
depends on what other
um Madness could happen at this club
queue because see Temple says here in
this tweet we shouldn't tolerate
pedophiles grooming kids
Club Q had a grooming event how do we
prevent violence and stop grooming oh my
God so basically what he's saying the
only way the only way to prevent this is
just to keep going just keep going the
only way to remove the grooming right
grooming event is to remove the groomers
right and the only way to remove the
groomers is to kill them right and
that's what he's advocating for and you
see that I mean like Matt Walsh is the
same way dude [ __ ] creepy oh no it
happened
yeah well I sent you that video of him
defending of it and it's and then we're
not gonna play it today because we just
ain't got enough time for that [ __ ]
piece of trash but Matt Walsh um was
recording some video in his car
right there that sentence alone makes
you worry
um you know honestly if we're gonna do
it on the side of the road probably
looking at some girl's window outside
like [ __ ] crazy it's really weird let
me tell you something if we're going to
investigate a private Citizen's laptop
we should investigate that one that's
always sitting in front of Matt Walsh
that has a little sticker that says what
are what is a woman because he doesn't
know what the hell they are yeah
um that's the laptop we should probably
investigate Tim pools probably get a
laptop we could look into too well but
it really is [ __ ] weird when you have
someone like Matt Walsh and Tim Poole
Matt Walsh specifically
um
they're supposed to be the experts on
grooming when they're doing videos
justifying justifying Catholic priests
molesting children
it's [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] it's weird
stuff it's we're and justifying Harvey
Weinstein's behavior in those videos
that that that I sent to you it's
[ __ ] weird man I mean and for people
who haven't seen the videos you should
go check it out it's on the Surfs uh
yeah yeah but to one of those things
that Tony brought up he was talking
about an actress and saying oh the
actress actually was okay with it yeah
she was sexually assaulted but she kept
going back so clearly she wanted it like
what kind of [ __ ] up deranged
perspective do you have to do do you
have to have to to victim blame and say
well she clearly wanted it because she
kept going back for it even though
it was it was rape it was sexual assault
right like it's just
here's here's the videos I'll actually
retweet the thread here so you guys can
find it
um that way that way you guys can find
it but um just to give you an idea We're
not gonna play the video because
I want my Thanksgiving to be happy yeah
um newly surfaced video of Matt Walsh's
has him giving extreme horrifying views
on consent rape age of consent of
consent
and has him defending multiple
pedophiles including cardinal mccarrick
whoosh
um apparently too now there this uh
there's three videos in that thread
but apparently Matt Walsh also and I
brought this up someone was
um saying and I don't know if it's a
written or it's a video
but for some reason he was justifying
Josh Duggar's Behavior now this is
before he was federally charged with
pornography job pornography but he was
justifying it at some point I don't
think it's video I think it's um some of
the written articles that he does is PR
in this Pro the written [ __ ] that he
does is probably even more vile trash
than the [ __ ] he records on video
um but and it is weird how these [ __ ]
[ __ ] pedophiles they all flock in the
same circles they all stroke each other
and say oh yeah this guy's good they're
not a creep they didn't do anything
illegal and then you find out oh this
person actually raped or sexually
assaulted or molested or whatever it
might be this person right especially
someone who's under age a minor Matt
Walsh is trending uh for those videos
that we were just talking about and his
vile [ __ ] beliefs on this cue stuff
um like it's at one point I was like
maybe Matt Walsh was a normal dude you
know here you go here here and then oh
God here's here's um so Arie says here
it took three days after mass shooting
of at Club Q for the daily wires Matt
Walsh to blame the victims for the
massacre
he did and then he responded wow these
[ __ ] races are really going all in with
the defamation today as the clip shows I
said no such thing oh so now he's the
victim here of course [ __ ] little of
course ass [ __ ] hey Matt Walsh send me
a cease and desist you [ __ ] weirdo do
it do it you [ __ ] weirdo you are
you're the person who who caused the
[ __ ] at Club Q you're one of them you
Tucker Carlson Ben Shapiro you [ __ ]
scumbags you've you're you're framing up
human beings people that live in this
country I'll say this I believe
that Matt Walsh
you know [ __ ] it Matt Walsh has child
pornography on his computers
I'll say it I'll say it I I Matt Walsh
has as child pornography Matt Walsh has
a transgender uh pornography or videos
on his computer I want it because here's
the thing let's just [ __ ] bring it to
Discovery let's open it up let's see
what's on the computers right if you had
to do all this research man I can
guarantee that when you're trying to
figure out what's a man what's a woman
what's a child right because clearly the
age of consent is much lower than uh
than what is legally allowed right now
for you right you want it to be 15 16
right it's okay to take it take
advantage of those children to take
advantage of those kids and you want to
blame other people for being [ __ ]
groomers when it's in fact a transgender
person that [ __ ] stops
uh the the the assailant the shooter
at this club Stomps his [ __ ] face in
with with the with the veteran who
tackled him right and pulled him down so
you know you know the other thing too
here about that and about him defamation
is the [ __ ] and the serfs has
done a great job on on on
um putting this on the open the
[ __ ] is used
um pictures of underage children in
topless underage children in his
documentaries without the [ __ ]
parents consent
um here again I'm telling you he's got
child pornography on his computers
here's how would you get it on that [ __ ]
right come challenge us [ __ ]
let's get in Discovery
um here is um here it here's the tweet
that I read earlier and here's the video
for context let's see what he says well
you know I didn't want to listen to this
[ __ ] scumbag but I want to see if
it's defamation family friendly drag
shows quote unquote have two purposes
one from the drag queen's perspective is
to satisfy their fetish for
cross-dressing in front of children oh
my God the other on a more macro level
is to indoctrinate children into queer
Theory to put it simply
the point of drag queen Story Hour and
the child the the supposed
family-friendly drag shows is to turn
your children queer
oh my God it is it is it is an it is a
performance and it is someone in a
costume reading a story to you Charlie
you know like um
like someone dressed up in a clown
costume right and they would have the
balloons and they make the balloon
animals our our is Matt Walsh gonna
claim that those people are trying to
get them into clown
um make them into clowns is that what he
is that what they're trying to do is
that what that is trying to do I don't
know Matt Walsh complain about [ __ ]
uh
uh uh debutante balls and [ __ ]
um you know
uh [ __ ] I'm playing on the name right
now the the pageants yeah the pageants
yeah I was talking about this earlier
yeah no hell no I don't hear them say
[ __ ] no because because that makes that
makes little girls that makes that
Grooms little girls to be sexy women and
that's Matt which is what he won right
well I mean I don't I'm not really sure
what Matt Walsh wants I think he's
suppressing a lot of [ __ ] but let's
listen that is the goal
and whenever you say that what I just
said right there is let me clip on me
any matters hello everybody on Twitter
um hello you [ __ ] hello yeah thanks for
saying hi to me
the people who invented it stated
explicitly that that is the point to
help children live clearly that's their
quote
okay
this guy is such a [ __ ] chucklehead
listen when you have a community of
people who are marginalized Community I
know Matt Walsh knows nothing about this
you can just tell by the way he looks
and the way he talks
that that community
when they have other people who are part
of that Community they feel safe they
feel safe with each other
and not only that they want to make sure
that other people who are in that
Community regardless of their sex their
gender their age their name their race
their religion have a safe space you
dumb [ __ ] what don't you get
about it your entire world Matt Walsh is
a safe space for white men your entire
[ __ ] world is a safe space trust me I
[ __ ] know I don't go anywhere or do
anything where I don't I don't feel like
it's a safe space for me because I'm a
white dude I'm a [ __ ] white dude in
the entire world is our safe space you
stupid piece of [ __ ]
and that's why this [ __ ] doesn't
get it that's why he doesn't get it
because he's not willing to open up his
[ __ ] brain and take a few seconds to
understand that just because you don't
have any empathy for for marginalized
groups doesn't mean that other people
shouldn't you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I
can't stand this [ __ ] and the
thing about the left is that what they
believe and what they do
all of it is so horrifying so perverse
so degraded that if you just quote them
then you somehow sound like the crazy
one if you quote what they are saying it
sounds crazy just to say it out loud
because it's so horrifying
yet it's true
quote me [ __ ] quote me go ahead quote
me that's actually the whole point of
the show folks to be quite honest with
you and I've talked about this in
private with Gabe is my ass is not going
to come here and give you [ __ ]
statistics I'm not going to beat around
the [ __ ] Bush I'm not going to give
it to you lightly I'm not going to serve
it up on a little platter so it you know
and sugar coat it for you no [ __ ] no I'm
gonna give it to you Bare Bones raw Rio
right in your [ __ ] face that way when
when pieces of [ __ ] like this try to
quote me he has a really difficult
[ __ ] time
because there ain't a goddamn thing that
this guy could do to [ __ ] claim that
somehow my I'm not [ __ ] masculine and
that I'm coming from a beta standpoint
you are a dumb [ __ ] and this
idea this idea that is the only Alpha
way is to be a [ __ ] bigot I would
like for you to go talk to the guy who
who was a straight man in the goddamn
drag bar who took down the gunman and
made sure to save people's [ __ ] lives
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that's an
alpha male not this guy on the screen
this [ __ ] who doesn't even know
who women is
also uh this is the reason the left
cares so much about go ahead go ahead no
no I'll bring it up at the end
the Sunday defend it so vigorously
because according to the left think
about this
according to the left
the drag queen child combination has
become dangerous they say it's a
lightning rod for violent backlash
right that's what they said and it's
greatly exaggerated of course mostly
it's invented out of whole cloth
actually but
but even by their version of events if
it's causing this much chaos and
violence
why do you insist on continuing to do it
if according to you it's like putting
people's lives at risk
if if the effort to have men
cross-dressing children is putting
people's lives at risk why are you still
doing it is it that important to you
now as always they try to flip the
burden around on us
they demand that we explained why we
object to children being exposed to drag
queens and we can't explain it and we
have and we will continue to because
it's very easy to explain drag is
inherently sexual and ideological it is
burlesque and it's not appropriate to
bring your child to a burlesque show
you disgusting freaks
whoosh this guy is just way off the
[ __ ] Mark Way Off the Mark never met
never met someone in the lgbtq community
in his [ __ ] life to think that that
somehow drag is sexual dude that is your
[ __ ] problem it is your problem if
you look at drag and it makes you feel
horny Matt Walsh that is your [ __ ]
problem that is a you thing I have never
watched drag I've never watched a TV
show where a dude's dressed in a woman
in a as a woman Mrs Doubtfire Mrs
Tootsie you go on and on and on and on
and got any kind of weird feelings and
thought that it was sexual you are the
[ __ ] weirdo here you dumb
[ __ ] just because someone puts
on a costume and dances around to music
and sings and dance doesn't mean it has
anything to do with sex that's a you
problem Matt Walsh that is a you thing
yeah and I can say from experience like
I know you know I've got a friend that I
used to work with who does drag I've
been to drag shows I've never walked in
and be like oh man this is so
inappropriate or oh man I feel very
uncomfortable no it was entertaining
it's a show right and they love what
they do
and also love the fact they don't have
to worry about somebody [ __ ] coming
in and shooting a place up right
like Colorado Springs that spot that guy
that we watch and everyone think on
Monday or Tuesday
he talked about how this was their space
there was a place where that Community
could go and now there's this Dark Cloud
that sits above them knowing that they
have to come back from this this
traumatic event but you've got Matt
walsher and you've got Tim Poole and
you've got all these other [ __ ]
idiots right now they're trying to push
this idea that oh they were grooming
they're grooming these kids show me a
[ __ ] kid that was in there show me a
kid that was in there
and if there was a kid they're [ __ ]
dead now
because of people like you because of
people like Matt Walsh and Tucker
Carlson all these people Tim Poole
even if there was a [ __ ] kid in there
you're okay with that kid now being dead
you're okay with that kid's life being
at risk because some person they are
wanted to act on them they are they are
because that's what it is let's let's
really call this [ __ ] out if there
really were kids in there and this was a
grooming event you just said it was okay
for a person to come in with an AR-15
and shoot up the place
that's what they're saying is okay
that's what they're saying is okay it's
okay it's okay that there was a kid that
might have died if there was in fact a
child there for a grooming event because
you know what we removed all the
groomers we shot the groomers
do you want to know who the groomers are
Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro Tucker Carlson
that that the shooter's [ __ ] Grandpa
those are the groomers that groom this
[ __ ] this bonehead into thinking that
he could go in and kill these people
with his [ __ ] rifle because he's got
a gun and when you got a problem that
gun will solve it and that is the [ __ ]
that's the groomers you are grooming
people to cause violence Jesus Christ he
basically said he basically threatened
the country Matt Walsh did that if you
don't stop doing drag shows there's
there's gonna be more shootings just
stop doing drag shows and you'll stop
having shootings at drag shows that's
basically what Matt Walsh said he's
threatening and I haven't heard this guy
I have not heard any of them I have not
heard any of them because right now and
even if they did set it it was a [ __ ]
one-line comment they all say thoughts
and prayers whatever [ __ ] over that
[ __ ] you know even last night's
shooting thoughts and prayers oh my God
we can never really do anything to
prevent this mass shooting it's not like
there was [ __ ] writing on the wall
that was literally spelled out in blood
with all of the people's lives right but
no
they I have not heard once oh the only
thing I've heard right now especially
for the Colorado Springs shooting is
gotta blame it was a grooming event it's
their fault it's it's the it's this and
that they don't want to acknowledge
these people as people they don't want
to acknowledge them as other humans this
pro-life crowd could give two shits
about them right they say at the end of
the day oh well the real problem the
real it was actually their fault they
did this to themselves they caused this
to happen oh if they should have had
someone to protect they should have I
think I saw someone Matt Walsh just said
it if you don't if you have a drag show
you're you're gonna be a Target because
you're groomers
and here's the thing the only people
that are actually caring about humans
Democrats trying to pass legislation to
help control our out of [ __ ] insane
control gun problem that we have I mean
last night you had a person that wanted
the manager went into Walmart and shot
the place while people were [ __ ]
shopping for their God damn Thanksgiving
meals
like no place is safe anymore to do what
you could do because Republicans have
made it so easy and have politicized and
driven this this wedge between people to
say oh they are the problem and the only
way to fix the problem is to remove it
or just come up with a stupid Q Anon
conspiracy theory like fake Gabe here I
was wondering when he was going to type
this in about Club Q because this was
going around the internet last night so
I'm sure his uncle oral posted it on
Facebook some fight games got to get
with the conspiracy theories here's Q
Anon here's Q Anon writing fake Gabe's
comments he says how do you know that
this had it and I'll say in Tucker
Carlson's voice because that's probably
what he's really thinking about how do
you know that the shooter wasn't turned
away from participating in this event
because he he has identified his
non-binary hey you dummy his attorneys
now that now that he's gonna have hate
crimes put on him are the ones who are
trying to make sure the judge identify
is non-binary if you go look at his
mother's post from Facebook from the the
time that the shooting was happened she
was using pronouns like him he
you [ __ ] idiot you you but you
boneheads you boneheads take any [ __ ]
bait and that's what the attorneys his
attorneys are doing is make sure you
boneheads take the bait and spread this
narrative that somehow this kid is
non-binary and how he which I don't give
a [ __ ] what pronouns he wants to have
he can have whatever [ __ ] pronouns he
wants I'm not scared of words I'm not
scared of [ __ ] words and I'm sure no
one else is either besides you
[ __ ] but it really is something
it really is something that you're gonna
turn him into one of them
the people who he was trying to kill
it really is funny it really is funny so
I I challenge you fake Gabe to keep it
up to keep it up and see and see where
the facts lead you on this case but I
guarantee you they're not going to lead
where you want to lead just like the
Paul Pelosi thing where you guys are
thinking it was some kind of [ __ ]
sexual Adventure went wrong or some
stupid [ __ ] I mean look at the end of
the day we have fake game in the
comments and it's funny because
his stupidity is just on display but
fake Gabe
you know he said he wants to meet me in
person but really I tried calling fake
game on the phone he he doesn't call me
back to set up a meeting I mean fake
Gabe is a 40-something year old balding
man who lives in a basement
in California that's defamation he said
it he said it he said in the chat he
lives not too far for me stuff out there
man it happens but fake Gabe is a
pathetic piece of [ __ ] so yeah he is
well you know I hope he comes back every
day and gives me the ball to set up on
the D and knock it out yeah so we can
knock it out of the park everyone
I know shit's crazy
but have a great holiday seriously go
eat some [ __ ] turkey and some ham eat
some ham if you're gonna have ham too
eat the lumpy mashed potatoes the smooth
mashed potatoes put put gravy on it put
corn in it whatever you want to eat the
homemade cranberry sauce or the canned
just just have a great time love your
family love everyone around you
um give thanks not for not for what uh
this fake history that we think
Thanksgiving is for but give thanks that
we have a country give thanks that we
have a democracy there's plenty of
things to be thankful for even though
it's not the made up white history of
Thanksgiving so uh do that and and uh be
safe be healthy yeah because it's going
around out there it's going around out
there so everyone We're not gonna have a
show tomorrow or Friday but again we
will put out a bonehead of the week pole
so be looking for that make sure you
subscribe right here on YouTube to find
that poll you can go to the community
tab
and you'll find the bone of the wheat
Bowl also go on Twitter at Tony
michaelspod Twitter's getting a little
glitchy it's almost like he doesn't have
anyone there to really think do you say
glitzy or Nazi well glitch glitchy sorry
I heard Nazi I heard not glitches well
you know it happens it happens also
download every single episode this week
all three of them
on Apple Spotify Google and make sure to
leave us a great review while you're
there we will be back on Monday I
promise same time same place on Monday
have a great holiday be safe be healthy
I love you Happy Thanksgiving see ya
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon